[Musique]
c'est l'histoire d'un tabou
celui de femme violée par ceux en qui
elles avaient toutes confiance et qui
devait les soigner
leur médecin
c'est l'histoire d'un scandale celui des
violeurs en blouse blanche dont les
agressions sont si souvent couvertes par
l'Ordre des médecins
[Musique]
Jacky dit avoir été violée par son
psychiatre lors de plusieurs
consultations
la première fois je vais partir et puis
grand il me prend il me dit vous sentez
que je vous désire Jacky je suis en
train de bander
et puis il me prend la main puis me la
mets sur son sexe
il me dit elle vous sentez j'ai du désir
pour vous
et là on a une relation un passage à
l'acte
du bout contre le radiateur il a peur du
cabinet en fait
[Musique]
nous sommes en octobre 2022
cela fait plus de 10 ans que nous
filmons Jacky année après année
[Applaudissements]
la première fois que nous la rencontrons
cet ancienne fonctionnaire habite en
Corse sur les hauteurs d'Ajaccio
elle a porté plainte contre son
psychiatre
c'est le début d'un long combat
judiciaire que nous allons filmer pas à
pas
un parcours qui commence par une
déception
allô
oui
elle vient d'apprendre que le juge a
conclu à un non-lieu
mais qu'il reconnaît quand même
l'existence des actes sexuels
en conséquence il y a eu de considérer
que Jean-Philippe Picard a eu des
relations sexuelles s'agissant du
fellation et de pénétration vaginale
avec sa patiente Jacky de Mare il
reconnaît quand même dans le papier qui
a eu fellation et pénétration dans son
cabinet
c'est grave
dans ce courrier le juge considère que
les deux adultes sont consentants
il ne prend pas en compte la relation
d'autorité entre un médecin et sa
patiente
quand on va voir un médecin psychiatre
on raconte sa vie
il s'est beaucoup de choses sur sur vous
qu'au niveau failles
votre fragilité
il a joué dessus
le psychiatre aurait profité des
vulnérabilités de sa patiente pour
sortir progressivement de son rôle de
soignant
[Musique]
que j'étais séduisante
que je me troublais que c'était une
jolie femme que j'étais intelligentes
comme ces autres patientes qui étaient
hystériques
comment ça me caresser les cheveux
à me faire des massages
à m'embrasser
Jacky a consulté ce psychiatre parce
qu'elle est tombée en dépression suite à
des agressions sexuelles subies depuis
son enfance
c'est quelqu'un qui a déjà subi et qu'on
va pouvoir contraindre assez facilement
et à qui on va pouvoir faire penser que
ce qui se passe c'est pas vraiment un
viol que même c'est ça qu'elle veulent
etc ça c'est une stratégie d'agresseur
de base c'est à dire choisir des
victimes et là le choix de la victime il
est fait sur une certaine fragilité
c'est ensuite inverser la culpabilité
c'est-à-dire laisser penser que en fait
tu le veux bien la confusion est-elle
chez des gens fragiles que ça risque de
pouvoir durer assez longtemps
elle a beaucoup hésité avant de porter
plainte
et à un moment donné je me suis dit pour
sauver ma vie mieux que la plainte
sinon je pense que je serai encore dans
son cabinet ou peut-être je me serais
suicidé et je l'aurais bien arrangé je
me serais bien tué
Jacquie ne s'est pas tu
elle a brisé l'omerta aux aides dénoncer
un notable et ses proches lui ont tourné
le dos
9 autres patientes victimes du même
docteur interrogé par le juge
d'instruction n'aurait pas eu le courage
de porter plainte
pour ne plus jamais croiser son
agresseur elle s'apprête à quitter la
Corse
si c'est tellement petit que tout le
monde se frôlé se connaît
mais sur Paris je serais mieux
on revient toujours à dire j'étais jolie
je subis la double peine parce que moi
je pars et lui il reste
ce qui va me manquer le plus c'est les
odeurs la mer et les montagnes
[Musique]
les violences sexuelles font dérailler
la vie des victimes
3 mois après avoir quitté son île et
Jacky vit dans la précarité
[Musique]
sans travail sans ressources elle est
sans domicile fixe
je vis d'abord chez une copine à
Montreuil
qui m'a gardé pendant un an et demi
après
[Musique]
je vis à droite et à gauche
ça veut dire que je n'ai pas de logement
fixe et tous les deux ou trois jours je
suis obligé de changer de logement
j'étais hébergé à Gif-sur-Yvette
à Ivry dans le 15e dans le 14e dans le
78 dans le 77
dans le 91
dans le 94
et dans des hôtels parisiens
j'aurais un petit pain aux raisins pas
comme ça
[Musique]
ce qui l'aide à tenir c'est qu'elle a
décidé de faire appel du non-lieu
prononcé par le juge
le juge sec qu'il y a d'autres victimes
ils sont signalés à la police mais que
c'est pas lui de chercher à la vérité à
tout prix hors de son champ de saisine
comment un juge d'instruction qui va à
charge et à 10 charges comprendre mais
qui s'est quand même dans son intime
conviction qui a des autres victimes
comment peut-il prononcer à nos lieux et
laisser continuer cet homme
je suis choquée
dans ce temps suspendu avant la
prochaine audience
isolé
c'est sur Internet qu'elle trouve du
réconfort
Facebook c'est mon lien c'est un réseau
social
[Musique]
où il y a beaucoup de victimes qui ont
vécu la même chose que moi on se
soutient mutuellement en fait je crie
sur Facebook je vais pas bien je me sens
mal je vais pas y arriver j'arriverai
jamais à la fin de la procédure
[Musique]
et aidez-moi où j'ai peur où j'ai peur
et des mois je suis comme une petite
fille perdue et des mois je me sens
seule et là mes copines de facebook
virtuelle me répondent et m'encourage ou
passe un coup de fil
il me dit si tu vas y arriver on est là
on va t'aider tu vas y arriver
c'est la plus qui ne guérilla plus fort
tu vas y arriver
et ça m'encourage et je vais mieux
[Musique]
des victimes de médecins nous en avons
rencontré plusieurs à une époque où la
parole des femmes était peu entendues
certaines ont choisi l'écriture comme
exutoire
Anne était mineur au moment des faits
je suis cette petite fille assise sur
les genoux de cet adulte si grand et
fort ce monsieur très costaud est bardé
de diplômes comme en général le serait
de décoration
et j'ignore ce qui va maintenant se
passer
j'ai peur
je suis un petit objet sans force à la
merci de ces grands bras
le monsieur m'embrasse sur les lèvres
il me traite comme une femme adulte que
je ne suis pas
[Musique]
l'homme dont elle parle et le docteur
Jean-Paul Guittet psychiatre au Mans
accusé d'agression sexuelle par
plusieurs de ses patientes il a été
sanctionné en fin de carrière
[Musique]
ce psychiatre devait aider Anne à
surmonter sa dépression après le suicide
de son grand frère
je le voyais depuis j'avais 14 ans et
demi
et puis il m'avait dit que si j'étais un
jour
vraiment en difficulté je pouvais passer
le voir à l'improviste et donc j'ai
beaucoup hésité mais comme il m'avait il
m'avait invité à venir le voir si ça
allait vraiment pas ce jour-là j'étais
particulièrement fragilisée donc je me
suis rendue chez lui et donc en fait bon
là il me voit il me fait signe d'entrer
entre avant on prend quelqu'un d'autre
finalement puisqu'il faut que je suis
dans cette salle d'attente et en fait je
fends l'arme je fends l'arme et là
en fait il m'attire à lui il me prend
par les mains il m'a attire à lui comme
ça
il m'embrasse sur la bouche et il me dit
un truc du style
je sais qu'il y a des liens comme ça qui
peuvent se créer mais je veux pas du
tout te faire mal c'est à peu près
peut-être que
il y a quelques mots que je fais varier
mais c'est à peu près le sens exalt la
phrase exacte
puis petit à petit aussi il passe sous
mes vêtements il met ses mains sur ma
poitrine
il joue toujours sur ses registres un
petit peu parallèles et différents
parlant de tendresse en parlant d'amitié
et puis en mêlant avec des choses plus
sexualisées en fait et ça crée une
confusion en moi parce qu'en plus je
suis jeune je suis ado j'ai jamais eu de
petit ami
c'était de me dire que il vous il
voulait être le premier à me faire
l'amour parce que ce serait avec
quelqu'un qui m'aimait c'est ça qui me
vendait en fait c'était ça saccam
c'était soi-disant prétendument c'était
un service qui me rendait en fait
[Musique]
comment on peut faire confiance à
quelqu'un après ça comment on peut
vraiment faire confiance parce que en
fait je me dis si ça avait été un
étranger dans la rue bah bien sûr que
j'aurais eu peur mais on sait qu'on peut
avoir peur des étrangers dans la rue le
type qu'on connaît depuis longtemps ça
faisait deux ans que je le connaissais
quand même moi j'avais j'avais déposé
les heures mais j'avais donné ma
confiance et au moment où je lui ai
donné c'est la blonde après on se dit
c'est difficile en fait de faire
confiance dans l'existence à même
accompagnant ou dans des relations on a
toujours peur de le payer très cher en
fait
Jacky la Corse est à Paris depuis 6 mois
elle attend toujours que la justice se
prononce en appel sur sa plainte contre
son psychiatre
face au silence imposée par l'attente de
son jugement elle se rapproche des
milieux féministes pour faire entendre
sa voix
[Musique]
ça va
la victime est devenue militante
qui a éclaté quelques mois auparavant à
galvaniser les collectifs féministes
le viol est devenu une affaire politique
DSK c'est un homme politique
d'importance qui risque d'être président
de la République qui tombe qui est
incarcéré et parce que il est pris
là-bas dans le sac pour dire sa joliment
c'était un c'est possible de faire
tomber quelqu'un qui viole pas chez nous
mais enfin quand même il est tombé deux
c'est possible qu'un homme politique de
haut niveau soit un violeur et soit
condamné ou en tous les cas sérieusement
empêché de continuer une carrière comme
ça c'est ce moment-là clé qui a commencé
à mon avis à retourner le vidéo public
[Musique]
si l'opinion publique commence à
entendre les victimes la justice
condamne toujours aussi peu les
agresseurs sexuels
[Musique]
en 2013
Jacky retourne encore pour la première
fois
elle est convoquée à la cour d'appel de
Bastia
c'est sa dernière chance de faire
condamner son psychiatre
que j'attends l'audience d'aujourd'hui
qui reviennent sur le nom de Dieu que
cet homme
associé
et que moi je suis reconnu en tant que
victime pour me reconstruire
ça commence
cette fois encore Jacky ne réussit pas à
se faire entendre
les juges considèrent que l'emprise
psychologique du médecin sur sa patiente
n'est pas caractérisée
ils connaissent pas bien le dossier de
dividence commise par les médecins et de
l'autorité que peuvent avoir un médecin
sur sur sa patiente
cette
facilité de d'entrer dans le corps de
l'autre dans son intimité en fait c'est
facile pour un médecin il va dire à une
patiente des habitants va se déshabiller
en fait
[Musique]
l'affaire se termine par un non-lieu
comme dans 99% des cas en France
l'agresseur présumée ne sera pas
condamné par la justice pénale
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Jacky a décidé de ne pas en rester là et
de faire appel à l'ordre des médecins
un ordre professionnel chargé entre
autres de juger les contentieux entre
les médecins et leurs patients
mais que pèse la parole d'une plaignante
face à un médecin jugé par ses confrères
quand il y a des violences sexuelles et
qu'une planète
arrive jusqu'au Conseil de l'Ordre la
plupart du temps il se passe rien
objectivement ils ont une position de
complice des agresseurs sexuels je peux
pas le dire autrement
quelques mois plus tard Jacky s'apprête
à passer devant cette justice le docteur
elle est avec un ami qui découvre la
ferme
à quelques jours de l'audience
elle est inquiète
tu crois que je vais arriver devant le
conseil de lendemain qui n'aime pas les
médecins donc il n'est plus confiance en
message je vais arriver tranquille je
vais arriver pas pente
devant moi
tu crois que ça me fait plaisir j'ai
peur d'aller voir un message je me fais
même plus soigner tellement j'en ai peur
il est psychiatre il sait que c'est une
connerie oui donc il devrait dire bon
bah j'ai fait une connerie avec ma
patiente c'est comme ça où on rectifie
on arrête la thérapie je sais pas où on
reste pas comme ça
et ça je pense que c'est un élément qui
est important aux États-Unis au Canada
tout est rapide tout psychiatre n'a pas
le droit d'avoir des relations amoureuse
sexuelle avec sa patiente même deux ans
après la fin de la thérapie parce qu'il
peut avoir une relation d'emprise mais
c'est des choses qui éventuellement
peuvent être peuvent amenés pour dire
regarder il y a des réflexions c'est pas
une relation normale
le Conseil de l'Ordre même si c'est pas
ce ne sont pas des juges
c'est une manière d'être reconnue aussi
d'une autre manière
je suis reconnue quand même comme avoir
été
abusé par un médecin
[Musique]
c'est à Marseille au conseil régional de
l'ordre des médecins que Jacky sera
entendu
[Applaudissements]
elle est accompagnée de son avocate et
d'une psychologue militante féministe
[Musique]
pour la première fois depuis trois ans
Jacky sera confronté à son agresseur
la chambre disciplinaire est composée de
plusieurs médecins et présidé par un
magistrat
quand on rentre il y a une espèce
d'estrade
il y a 12 hommes qui siègent habillé en
noir et rouge
puis oui c'est assez impressionnant quoi
c'est solennelle et puis il y a des
tables puis
si car sur le côté gauche avec son
avocat moi sur le côté droit avec mon
avocate
et en fait quand j'ai croisé son regard
et
j'avais plus peur de lui en fait
c'est important j'avais plus peur de lui
il me regardait pas
[Musique]
le psychiatre risque un simple
avertissement
un blâme ou une radiation temporaire
[Musique]
la décision est rendue deux mois plus
tard
de ses patients les relations intimes
constituent une faute susceptible d'être
sanctionné par les instances
disciplinaires de la profession et une
interdit aux docteur Jean-Philippe
Sicard d'exercer la médecine pendant la
durée d'une année waouh
l'accention visible dessus prendra effet
le premier juillet 2014 à 0 heure pour
s'achever le 30 juin 2015 à 24 heures
c'était une victoire pour moi
un an de radiation
pour prendre la mesure de la sanction
oui vous m'entendez mieux là Jacquie
appelle le conseil de l'ordre de
Marseille oui vous m'entendez
moi j'ai l'impression d'être reconnu
comme victime mais en plus l'année de la
motivation et bien écrit quand même
l'ascendant du médecin la dépendance que
l'on a par rapport à son médecin
la sanction aurait pu être plus lourde
après là c'est dommage je vous cache pas
que je regrette qu'il n'y ait pas eu
d'autres cas simultané avec vous c'est
qu'à avéré quand j'étais portée plainte
à la police ils ont ils ont ils ont été
ils ont fait une perquisition à son
combiné ils ont interrogé pense sur
trois ans toute sa patienter là ils ont
retrouvé 9 victimes une victime qui
n'ont pas voulu porter plainte parce
qu'elles avaient peur
et c'est parfait
bonne journée
que le docteur Sicard va faire appel ce
qui lui permettra de continuer à exercer
[Musique]
c'est un procès inédit qui s'ouvre
aujourd'hui devant la cour d'assises de
Paris dans le box le docteur André azout
gynécologue réputé reconnu pour ses
travaux sur la fécondation in vitro il
va pourtant devoir répondre à 6 de ses
anciennes patientes qu'il l'accusent
d'agression sexuelle et de viol
[Musique]
à mi-chemin entre l'affaire DSK et le
mouvement Mitou pour la première fois un
médecin accusé de viol fait la une de la
presse nationale
ce procès va révéler l'inaction du
Conseil de l'Ordre
à l'origine de la ferme le couple Cécile
et Richard poivvain
ils ont consulté le docteur azout dans
l'espoir d'avoir un enfant
les faits se sont produits quand Cécile
était seul en consultation elle en parle
immédiatement à son mari
je l'ai évidemment cru parce que ça je
pense que c'est peut-être la différence
avec certains
certains conjoints au Barry qui
ont fait que certaines femmes leur ont
pas parlé parce qu'elles avaient peur de
leur réactions ou d'une réaction au
contraire de jalousie moi moi je l'écris
tout de suite et je l'ai soutenu et
voilà et puis on est parti
on est parti en guerre quelque part tous
les deux ça fait 9 ans que ça dure 9 ans
de notre vie quand même pour éviter un
non-lieu Richard et Cécile ont d'abord
dû trouver par eux-mêmes d'autres
victimes
telles qu'elle a été réalisée cette
agression je me doutais qu'il y avait
certainement d'autres d'autres cas donc
j'en ai j'ai laissé des
disons j'ai tendu des perches sur
internet par un pseudo sur de deux sites
d'opticaux et féminin.com au féminin com
de manière à savoir si des femmes
avaient pu être agressées par ce même
médecin
et voilà c'est comme ça qu'on a récupéré
assez facilement je dois dire
le couple a retrouvé une quarantaine de
victimes présumées témoignant
d'agressions commises pendant plusieurs
dizaines d'années par le docteur azout
le fait que un violeur
n'est qu'une pulsion et que ne fasse
qu'un viol ça c'est dans les rêves des
personnes en vrai un violeur sait un
violeur c'est à dire qu'il pense en
violeur du coup évidemment il y a plein
de victimes et maintenant qu'on a
réfléchi et penser autour de ça ici à la
permanence téléphonique depuis une
quinzaine d'années on demande aux
personnes qui nous appellent mais vous
savez si la violet d'autres personnes et
plus de 50% des victimes savent qu'il a
violé d'autres personnes ils connaissent
donc en vrai je pense pas qu'il y a un
seul violeur qui ne violent qu'une fois
les faisceaux concordants c'est-à-dire
des témoignages
identiques pour des faits identiques par
des personnes qui ne se connaissent pas
clairement ça pour nous en tout cas ça a
été effectivement ce qui a fait que
aujourd'hui il est renvoyé devant les
assises
pour Jacky dont le médecin n'a pas été
condamné au pénal le procès du docteur
azout est un procès par procuration
en fait quand j'ai rencontré d'autres
victimes de médecins j'ai trouvé une
solidarité
je leur apportais mon soutien
parce qu'on a aussi des histoires
différentes mais c'est à peu près les
mêmes histoires
il y a une solidarité on a un socle
commun c'est qu'on était victime de
violences commises par des médecins en
fait
face au docteur azote si victime
reconnue
et 30 autres femmes venu témoigner pour
des faits prescrits comme Marie
dit j'ai toujours été sincère
la sincérité c'est pas des excuses
moi j'ai arrêté de vivre j'avais 25 ans
j'en ai 52 bientôt
et j'ai arrêté toute une partie de ma
vie il me reste quoi moi maintenant j'ai
pas d'enfants il m'a cassé qu'est-ce
qu'il me reste
il me reste rien
j'ai pu rien
j'ai la rage je suis
j'ai une page à tourner je vais pas je
vais pas y arriver comme ça et je
pensais que ça sera un exutoire que ce
serait la seule manière de de me sortir
de ça et je m'en sortirai pas
je m'en sortirai pas c'est une blessure
ouverte et j'attends beaucoup de cet
après-midi mais j'ai
je sais que ce sera pas fini
l'avocat général a requis 12 ans
d'incarcération
après plusieurs semaines de procès le
médecin violeur est condamné à 8 ans de
prison
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que vous avez ressenti
voilà
j'ai besoin de rentrer chez moi
maintenant
vous avez le sentiment que votre parole
a été entendue le fait que le viol était
reconnu est-ce que c'est pour vous
l'impression d'avoir été entendu par les
jurés par la Cour
moi
j'ai tout ce qui est merveilleux sans
doute aujourd'hui c'est que d'avoir été
entendu de tous ces discours qui ont été
tenus
une justice bien tardive car le conseil
de l'ordre avait reçu des plaintes
depuis les années 90 et n'avait pas
réagi
c'est à faire a été un désastre
ordinal
le Conseil de l'Ordre doit donc
réfléchir sur les règles qui consistent
avant tout à protéger les patientes
lorsque elles viennent faire des
dénonciations ici je rappelle qu'il a
fallu 25 ans pour qu'enfin effectivement
le Conseil de l'Ordre prenne une
disposition nécessaire
ce procès il a montré que oui des
médecins êtes pouvaient être violeurs et
qui pouvaient être condamnés et ça pour
nous c'est important et puis ça pas
suffi complètement pour que le Conseil
de l'Ordre continue à
défendre les femmes victimes mais ça a
été un premier pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un an à passer
de nouveau Jacky va devoir affronter son
ancien psychiatre qui a fait appel de sa
condamnation à un an de radiation
salut ça va tu vas bien oui
elle est entourée de membres du
Collectif féministe contre le viol
debout à quelques mètres d'elle le
médecin qu'elle accuse de violence
de la part du conseil de l'ordre
national des médecins c'est d'accueillir
les victimes de gens sexuelle de la part
d'amitié
dans une petite salle
d'accueil face à son agresseur c'était
d'une violence inouïe
[Musique]
au moment de l'audience le docteur
exerce toujours car l'appel est
suspensif
[Applaudissements]
devant ses confrères le psychiatre ni le
viol
et puisque les actes sexuels ont été
reconnus par la justice
il accuse son ancienne patiente
d'érotomanie
inverser la culpabilité c'est en
permanence la stratégie des agresseurs
sexuels
donc le médecin y compris lui ce qui
veut que tu crois quand tu es victime
c'est que c'est toi qui voulais que tu
la cherchais que lui il a bien été
gentil mais en fait quand on analyse ce
qui s'est passé c'est exactement le
contraire elles sont tombées dans des
pièges elles ont pas vu quand ça se
passait
mais
c'est vraiment une vraie stratégie une
toile d'araignée dans laquelle elles
peuvent difficilement résister
[Applaudissements]
face à la chambre disciplinaire la
défense du docteur Sicard a fonctionné
la chambre réduit de moitié sa
condamnation
j'ai beaucoup pleuré énormément pleuré
mais c'est pas je me suis j'ai pas eu
l'impression qu'il m'écoutait en fait
c'était je
protège mon confrère en fait
le psychiatre est puni de 6 mois de
radiation à effet immédiat
rares sont celles qui parviennent à se
faire entendre par la justice ordinale
15 ans après avoir fréquenté le cabinet
du docteur Guittet au Mans devenu
journaliste Anne a signalé au Conseil de
l'Ordre les agressions sexuelles qu'elle
dit avoir subi quand elle était mineure
elle est la troisième patiente à mettre
en cause ce psychiatre
mais c'est elle qu'on accuse de s'être
jeté dans ses bras
sa plainte et rejeté par les médecins
ce sont des hommes assez âgés et donc
effectivement je pense que c'est une
certaine culture aussi qui s'exprime et
c'est comme ça aujourd'hui que je
comprends la décision qui a été prise
contre moi d'aller affirmer contre toute
évidence que je c'était moi qui avait
pris l'initiative de
ce qui s'était passé avec avec ce
professionnel de santé sans souci aucun
pour les conséquences pour moi d'une
telle affirmation en plus parce que
c'est gravissime je veux dire on a déjà
beaucoup de culpabilité beaucoup de
honte et en plus ces gens-là viennent
donner un bâton à l'agresseur pour vous
continuez à vous taper sur la figure
c'est vraiment c'est froyable en fait
comme
et puis et puis c'est désespérant moi
j'ai été désespérée je me suis dit mais
en fait je vis dans un monde qui n'a
aucun sens c'est un sens et en fait de
recevoir ce type de verdict donc en fait
quelque part j'ai eu l'impression d'être
responsable du fait que c'est individu
continue à faire du mal et ça je l'ai
porté seul puisque ces gens-là n'en
avaient strictement rien à faire
il aura fallu attendre une cinquième
accusatrice pour qu'il lui soit interdit
de recevoir des patientes mineurs
38 ans après la première plainte
[Musique]
le Conseil de l'Ordre est parfois plus
sévère avec ceux qui dénoncent les
violences qu'avec les violeurs
c'est ce qui s'est produit dans
l'affaire du docteur azuks
Richard poitevin le mari de Cécile la
plaignante était lui-même médecin chef
de service dans un hôpital en
Île-de-France
pour avoir dénoncé auprès des
institutions ordinales le viol de sa
femme il a été puni d'un blâme
c'est la sanction qui précède la
radiation
ce qui m'est arrivé c'était en 2004 et
la promenade première plainte elle est
quand même auprès du Conseil de l'Ordre
date de d'avril 2005
je prenais à risque et
effectivement j'ai eu ce blâme pour pour
diffamation mais
Seigneur pour ça après je je n'arrivais
plus enfin j'ai eu du mal à accepter
tout cela
[Musique]
très affecté il a dû quitter son service
et déménager dans le sud de la France
[Musique]
sont sanctionnés par les chambres
disciplinaires de l'ordre pour avoir
signalé des violences commises sur des
femmes ou même des enfants en matière de
violence sexuelle il s'ennuie
ils sont nettement complices les
agresseurs sexuels c'est à dire un il
protège les collègues qui sont présumés
à grâce asexuels deux ils engueulent les
collègues qui dénoncent des agressions
sexuelles auprès des enfants donc ça
pour moi c'est objectif je sais pas
pourquoi ils sont comme ça mais
effectivement c'est ça que ça donne
comme notion il y avait un journal du
conseil de l'Orne où il y avait les
condamnations je me souviens il y avait
un gars qui était condamné à 8 jours de
suspension d'exercice professionnel
parce que il avait fait faire une
fellation un petit enfant de 5 ans au
moment de d'un examen ORL et c'était 8
jours de suspension
et c'était décrit comme ça
tranquillement mais c'était il y a 35
ans quand il sortait des papiers donc
maintenant je l'ai plus je sais plus
mais quand même on est dans des trucs de
fou quoi
ce sont de jeunes filles tombées dans un
effroyable piège celui de Jeffrey
Epstein reachons
du cinéma français elle accuse le
cinéaste Christophe c'est le récit
glacial d'une jeune fille sous emprise
et il secoue le monde de l'édition avant
même sa sortie le consentement de
Vanessa springora raconte j'avais 21 ans
lui 36 de plus Florence Porcel vient de
déposer plainte contre Patrick Poivre
d'Arvor
icône cathodique
depuis la déflagration du mouvement
Mitou les victimes de violences
sexuelles sortent du silence qui leur a
été imposé
sur les réseaux sociaux dans les médias
et dans la rue elles savent se faire
entendre
la parole ne s'est pas libérée c'est la
société qui enfin écoute et croient les
victimes
[Musique]
mais ce changement de paradigme a-t-il
touché l'ordre des médecins
au siège de l'institution ordinale en
2021 les consignes ont changé
les échelons départementaux de l'ordre
sont appelés à mieux écouter les
plaignants
dans les faits à connotation sexuelle
nous invitons très fortement les
conseils départementaux à porter plainte
contre les médecins et qui auront à
répondre avec le respect des droits de
la défense devant les chambres
disciplinaires
un des comportements qui leur sont
reprochés par la plaignante on peut
surtout pas se réfugier derrière le fait
que ces paroles contre parole on ne veut
plus on ne peut plus l'entendre et c'est
très clair il y a aucune ambiguïté
aucune ambiguïté là-dessus
un an plus tard l'ambiguïté demeure
dans cette ville du Pas-de-Calais
70 femmes âgées de 27 à 47 ans ont porté
plainte contre le même gynécologue
le docteur Bernard Henri pour agression
sexuelle et viol
[Musique]
vendeuse enseignante
infirmière
fonctionnaire de police
psychologue comptable
assistante de direction
auditionné par le juge d'instruction
toutes décrivent des séances sexuelles
des récits concordants de femmes qui ne
se connaissent pas
ils mettaient plusieurs doigts toujours
son pouce sur le clitoris avec une main
au-dessus et en fait il faisait des sens
des va-et-vient et en bougeant la main
je sens un moment donné un souffle
et un passage de langue
quelques minutes après je ressens le
souffle et je me dire comment
un deuxième passage de langue
mais parfois ça durait très longtemps je
me souviens d'une fois où ça m'avait
vraiment fait mal parce que c'était tout
ça qui à force des va-et-vient je lui ai
dit il s'est un petit peu énervant que
c'était bientôt terminé dans une
troisième respiration au niveau du
tourisme
et j'ai le droit à notre passage de
langue et j'entends des bruits de tissus
et il me dit je vais tout fini
je me dis c'est pas possible il est en
train de se faire plaisir
l'affaire est en instruction depuis 7
ans mise en examen le docteur Henry
reçoit toujours des patients
le Conseil de l'Ordre du Pas-de-Calais
ne l'a pas suspendu
la justice lui interdit d'exercer la
gynécologie mais l'autorise à exercer
une autre de ses spécialités
elle continue d'exercer au terme de du
contrôle judiciaire dont il est astreint
il continue à exercer l'endocrinologie
dans son cabinet et vous dire que c'est
particulièrement difficile pour mes
clients d'accepter malgré le fait qu'il
soit
présumé innocent qu'ils puissent encore
exercer la médecine
il a toujours accès au corps des femmes
en tant qu'endocrinologue il fait
l'objet d'une nouvelle plainte pour viol
combien faut-il de témoignages pour
qu'on écoute la parole des femmes
au conseil national de l'ordre des
médecins cette fois c'est une femme qui
répond
en tant que femme médecin je suis
terriblement impactée
par ces faits là
je lis la presse comme tout le monde et
quand je lis ces témoignages
je suis horrifiée bien sûr c'est
difficile d'envisager que quelqu'un de
sa corporation puisse
violenter avoir
des attitudes inappropriées allant
jusqu'à la violence sexuelle et
le viol je vais dire quelque part voilà
comment vous vous expliquez vous que le
Conseil de l'Ordre ne suspente pas à
titre provisoire ce médecin qui a 70
plaintes aujourd'hui au pénal et qui est
mis en examen de depuis 2015 alors je
peux pas commenter des affaires pourquoi
parce qu'elles sont en cours là c'est
lié je veux dire et ça je pense que
l'institution ordinaire a fait le semer
à coup pas c'est lié à une inaction à un
certain moment mais pourquoi la chambre
disciplinaire ne radit pas
automatiquement des médecins c'est pas
de la mauvaise foi ce que je suis en
train de vous dire mais par contre pour
le cas dont vous me parlez
écoutez on attend on attend la décision
de la chambre disciplinaire voilà
non seulement le Conseil de l'Ordre a le
plus grand mal à sanctionner mais il ne
signale pas l'effet dont il a
connaissance à la justice
cette inertie explique pourquoi des
médecins accusés par de nombreuses
patientes continuent d'exercer
impunément pendant des dizaines d'années
mais aujourd'hui les violences commises
par des soignants sont devenus
inacceptables
une nouvelle génération de femmes exige
de pouvoir exprimer son consentement
avant tout acte médical
c'est pas parce qu'il y a des
spécialités ou effectivement on rentre
dans l'intimité de la personne qu'on
doit les abuser et les violer et je veux
dire que les choses soient claires c'est
pas parce qu'une femme va à sa
consultation de gynécologie le
consentement est acquis voilà mais tout
ça c'est des paradigmes qui changent il
y a 30 ans on pouvait considérer qu'une
femme qui allait en gynécologie faire
une consultation le consentement était
acquis parce que finalement les luttes
et les débats féministes il y a plus de
30 ans c'était quoi c'était la
contraception c'était la légalisation de
l'avortement maintenant on est quand
même dans d'autres dimensions qui font
que
on est dans le recueil du consentement
[Musique]
l'ordre des médecins promet de se mettre
au diapason de son époque
mais l'institution a toujours eu un
train de retard sur la société
il y avait dans le temps un truc sur une
participera pas à l'avortement le
Conseil de l'Ordre ça a été créé par
Pétain et c'est un vieux truc très
réactionnel quand même
après des années a tenté d'oublier
l'histoire d'Anne lui revient de manière
inattendue
en décembre 2019 la Cour des comptes
publie un rapport sévère sur l'ordre des
médecins
[Musique]
elle y dénonce les manquements nombreux
en matière de déontologie
et réclame des garanties de procès
équitables pour les citoyens
[Musique]
dans les pages consacrées aux agressions
sexuelles Anne reconnait son affaire
en fait je m'étais toujours sentie
comment dire
illégitime à parler parce qu'en fait
j'avais complètement intériorisé leur
jugement négatif et le fait qu'ils
avaient prétendu je m'étais précipité
sur sur la personne et tout tout ce
discours inversé sur sur mes actes et
sur ce qui s'était vraiment passé donc
je n'osais pas trop parler et puis tout
d'un coup ce rapport m'a donné une forme
de légitimité pour m'exprimer et je me
suis dit à partir de là je vais je vais
recenser un peu régulièrement toutes les
violences sexuelles commisses par des
professionnels de santé par des médecins
que je peux trouver dans je peux trouver
mention dans les journaux sur le web etc
depuis trois ans elle anime le hashtag
violence sexuelle médecin suivi par 2000
personnes
à un moment donné il y avait une ou deux
affaires qui sortaient par semaine
médiatiquement c'est énorme en France
j'ai interpellé les ministres de la
Santé successifs depuis Agnès Buzyn donc
Olivier Véran et puis maintenant
François Brown j'ai interpellé d'autres
ministres comme Elisabeth Moreno et
maintenant Isabelle Rome
j'ai interpelle aussi la commission des
affaires sociales de l'Assemblée
nationale puisque il me semble qu'elle
pourrait serait légitime à agir sur ce
sujet la délégation droit des femmes de
l'Assemblée nationale je n'ai obtenu
aucune réaction d'aucune sorte d'aucun
ministre je meurs à une totale
indifférence sur le sujet mais en fait à
ma connaissance il n'y a pas de réponse
officielle sur les suites données à ce
rapport et sur sur les réformes mises en
œuvre
c'est sens aujourd'hui de ce hashtag
pour moi aussi c'est de faire en sorte
vraiment que le système soit réformé et
qui soit qui soit qui soit assainies et
qu'on puisse effectivement qu'il soit
digne de confiance
il y a 5 ans jour pour jour paraissaient
dans le New York Times l'enquête qui
fera tomber l'un des producteurs les
plus influents d'Hollywood Harvey
Weinstein et qui donnera naissance
quelques jours plus tard au hashtag
lancés par l'actrice Alice Milano me too
deux petits mots qui ont changé le monde
et ouvert la voie à une nouvelle
génération féministe
depuis cinq ans le mouvement Mitou a
gagné de nombreuses professions le sport
le cinéma les médias la politique
et qu'en est-il du monde des médecins
à ma connaissance il y a pas de mes tous
mais peut-être que il y en a peut-être
un dans un coin qu'on a pas vu mais pour
moi j'ai pas vu encore de choses comme
ça
[Musique]
voici 11 ans que nous rencontrons des
victimes de médecins
que nous écoutons leur souffrance
11 ans qu'elle réclame une justice
équitable
pour mettre fin à la complaisance envers
les violeurs en blouse blanche
n'est-il pas temps de mettre en cause le
Conseil de l'Ordre
et de faire des médecins des
justiciables comme les autres
je vais mieux
mais souvent encore quand même de stress
post-traumatique
[Musique]
la reconstruction est passe par déjà
l'estime de soi
et consoler la petite fille que j'étais
qui a souffert aussi et consoler même la
jeune femme ou la femme que j'ai été
cassé
et que quand même la vie est belle et
que ça vaut le coup de la vivre
même si c'est que des instants de
bonheur ou des petits moments de bonheur
il faut les prendre à peine d'en fait
[Musique]